it was definitely hard there was a large
period of time we were like I don't know
if we can do this this may not just work
it just doesn't work but wait with the
mechanics titanfall you can't be like
well let's just get rid of that Titan or
nope no wall running and double jumping
Respawn Entertainment is bringing its
kinetic franchise back this October with
titanfall to the successor to the game
that spawned a new era of multiplayer
shooters focused on fluid player
movement and while the sequel is adding
the expected fare like new tying of
pilot classes it's also branching into a
new area for respawn entirely a single
player campaign so when we start
titanfall 2 was not a foregone
conclusion like oh well just got a
single player that checkbox has to be
done we took a long hard look at what
did we want to do is a studious judging
by a recent single player demo I
response headquarters the studio is
embracing the challenge of adopting the
tying fall formula for a single player
experience the park or system remains as
does the interplay between Pilate and
Titan combat in fact respawn is
embracing its roots so much that the
campaign's very level design is tailored
around the franchise's signature style
time fall to director Steve Fukuda said
this is intentional the studio wants to
do something new without completely
shirking what made time 'full unique to
begin with the way we worked at eiffel
to is very interesting because we worked
on it quite bottom up where we sort of
started with what is the essence of
titanfall titanfall is essentially two
games layered on top of each other
merged together one is the pilot
mobility game which is just sliding wall
running and grappling two places the
other game is of course Manning a Titan
and fighting other Titans in the
battlefield and then the two of them
converge that confluence has been very
it's a very challenging balance to hit
that is while many military shooters
rely on linear corridors titanfall tues
environments are set up like a series of
arenas allowing you to wall run double
jump and vault up to sniper perches and
many sandbox firefights there's an
arcade like quality to the missions
respawn showed at the recent preview
event and not just in the single-player
level designs we will have to improvise
any jobs if we wish to survive there's
also a personal quality to the
campaign's writing as it follows
rifleman James Cooper into foreign
environments alongside his newfound
Titan BTW 72-74
and so we thought we said what is the
essence of this game well that is that
it is the pilot the Titan okay let's
bring that over to a single player
viewpoint what does that mean well
narrative Lee if you take a narrative
look at it that seems to suggest that
there are two so there's a buddy it
implies a sort of buddy relationship ok
let's look at all kinds of buddy
relationships Laurel and Hardy you have
rigs and Murtagh and lethal weapon
basically have these buddy stories he
can look through history of what is a
buddy story like how long did you serve
with lastimosa captain lost the most of
linked with me 973 days ago
it's longer than any relationship I've
had respawn seems to be going for comedy
intimacy and jargon istic military
tropes all at once and based on the
mission we saw it might be working so
that all sort of is what fed into
inspiring us to do a single player and
take how single player took on that form
of hey it's about the pilot and the
Titan and their relationship
fundamentally both gameplay wise and
narrative Lee and emotionally
the last feature shown in the demo was
also one of the most notable by jumping
into some sort of quick select screen
Cooper switched bt's Titan load out on
the fly so while he began with the
energy based I on equipment set he
quickly changed to the scorch loadout
respawn has only announced three time
varying so far but judging by the single
player demo the campaign will grant
access to the same six classes as multi
player respawn is stressing that the
single-player campaign isn't an
afterthought the studio didn't tack on
this two piece fans who demand a single
player experience with their sixty
dollar price tag as numerous members of
the studio said this is the game they
always wanted to make multiplayer
single-player boss fights and all for a
single player was a chance to expand on
this universe that people really did
gravitate to in this first game even
those multiplayer only as well as we
really want to bring more people to our
party if you will like hey we're over
here having fun while running double
jumping getting in a giant robots
blowing stuff up and there are people
who don't want to go online and deal
with the stress of the competitive game
and we want to bring them in you want
them to have this kind of fun too so it
was really our goal to expand that
audience of people who can enjoy
thankful this is just a first look at
time fall to single-player campaign be
sure to stay tuned next week for
multiplayer impressions gameplay and not
just a deep look into what respawn has
learned from its previous title but how
it plans to implement it into titanfall
2 thanks for watching
vision